first of all uh congrats on being part
of a very very cool movie
uh that totally works um i so i am
curious for both of you
when you're presented with do you want
to be an orion
ryan reynolds movie do you immediately
think this is all part of an episode of
punk'd
that's the only way to describe actually
yeah it doesn't feel like like i i feel
like i was lucky enough to meet him once
and then i was like that's it we're done
that's career highlight i
never have to do anything else again and
then they came back with this so
it's insane yeah i think as well there's
so many other great people in here too
like i'm a big fan of jody comas too
so being in in a in a film with
all these great people is just is wild
i'm curious when you are presented with
something like this how much are you
asking them questions like
please tell me about how gamers are
going to be described or portrayed in
the film
and how much is it sort of like wait i
can be in a movie with ryan reynolds i'm
good
just where do i need to be
i'd say it's a lot more column b steve
[Laughter]
but i i think my fears for that were
laid when
i had a call with the director and he
was talking about the movie and he
he like stopped and gave me time to talk
about it and said like well how do we do
this how do we make sure that we don't
like do stuff that every other video
game movie is done and i was like well
just
don't put in all the terms and the
cringy dialogue and stuff that people
expect like
you don't need the name of the game in
it you don't need like
x y and z all the time and like just
describing let's plays and things like
that to him he
he seemed very receptive so it seemed
like they just really took it on board
and wanted to make just the best movie
possible
um and i think that that comes across
very very well
um they just wanted to make something
that represented the gaming community
the best that they could yeah i think
their willingness to
actually listen to us rather than just
be like here's your lines this is what i
need you to do
it was more of a how can we make this
work and feel
the best way possible to fit so
naturally into the film
i think they pulled that off really well
i think that video games when you look
at what they've started with back in
like the atari
age in the 70s to where we are now it's
incredible
the how much the the industry has grown
and what you can do
what are things that you would love to
see in a video game that aren't there
now that maybe are
on the cusp of getting there i think vr
is the next big thing
yeah too we've had some stuff kind of
dabble into vr and it's usually like
wave shooters
and there's a couple of cool things a
couple of cool games that try new stuff
but at the end of the day they also
feel very video gamey but half-life alex
was the first one that came out that
really kind of like
set the bar for high-end triple a big
budget like story-driven character
driven action and i feel like that's
kind of what movies are always about you
always fall in love with the characters
in the setting
and that's sometimes that's where video
games fall short sometimes that's not
their aim at all but a game like
half-life alex showed me like oh this
can be
incredibly immersive if we get to that
point and if you have those set pieces
from movies like
literally on your face as you're looking
around interacting with it
i think that's like a next level thing
that we've talked about since like the
80s
that is just around the corner yeah it's
it's so immersive like every time i
i play vr even if it's like 30 minutes i
take the headset off and i'm like
oh yeah i was playing a game yeah
whereas you could like instead of
playing as the main character you are
the main character
i've seen crazy things where you can i
don't know where like a laptop on your
back
and then you're tracking like an empty
warehouse but you're playing like a full
first person shooter in vr that kind of
stuff
i i think once they push vr to the max
it's gonna be
it's gonna be insane yeah i think movies
and vr are gonna like coalesce very well
together
i have not done this vr thing in a
warehouse and i am super jealous
that sounds you should no that's that's
all my now it's on my list
uh i i i think for both of you guys
you're
very successful at what you do i'm
curious
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about being a professional
gamer being
having to broadcast all the time what
are some things that
would surprise people i think people
think it's a lot
more glamorous than it is or maybe
glamorous isn't the right word i think
they think it's a lot different than it
is
that because you're giving people
bite-sized chunks of your life
and it's through the lens of what we do
here that
you tend to have like a certain
perception of it the same way you watch
like actors and movies you feel like you
get a sense for who they are and
while we're genuine to who we are online
and we're not trying to like
pull the wool over anyone's eyes there's
still elements of us that you don't know
you don't know us as people we have our
own lives separate to all of that we
interact with things
in the real world that you never get to
see and i think that element of it
is something that i've always tried to
portray that
no i'm still just a person that i have
my ups and downs i'm not all
happy-go-lucky
all the time that i have bad days and i
sometimes i like to just sit around
in my underwear watching tv all day and
that's also
nice about our platform is we can be
that that personable i think that's why
people relate to
us and other youtubers so well and
that's why it's so good
it's so cool to have like that
opportunity in the film because i think
that will resonate when people see
us in the film too they'll be like oh i
i know that that person
i think it's easy to like get big on
youtube and get big on any sort of
platform by
delivering bad news all the time and
kind of feeding into that negativity but
i feel like we have a
a grasp on it where we we try and
promote the healthier more positive side
of things and i
i feel like i feel like that goes a long
way with people
and kind of gels better and kind of
creates that sense of community stronger
than anything else on that note congrats
again on being part of a cool film
and uh good luck with the rest of your
speed dating thank you
haven't met the right one yet